sur internet nathalie se laisse porter
par un échantillon gratuit de crème anti
âge qui promet de la réduire de 10 ans
elle n'a que les frais de livraison à
payer mes quinze jours après son achat
nathalie découvre que la compagnie des
800 $ sur sa carte de crédit
elle se rend compte que chaque mois elle
recevra un nouveau tube de crème puis
reprendre à 100 dollars de quoi lui
donner tout un coup dur il aurait fallu
qu'elle lise qui est écrit ici c'est ce
que personne n'a envie de lire
elle devait annuler il essaie dans les
14 premiers jours pour ne pas être
abonné mais nathalie ne la peau nue el
amel cochet qu'elle acceptait ce contrat
essayez vous tiré de ce bourbier
maintenant vous faire rembourser
c'est comme mettre de laquelle dans un
tube le mieux que vous pourrez faire
c'est d'arrêter l'abonnement le fin mot
de l'histoire
pour éviter que l'achat d'une crème
réjouissante ne vous donnent des cheveux
blancs agissez en singe lisez tout